[Música]
r
o software oficial confessou
Oh
participante
wisner é mostrado como um disco
[Música]
chamado multi peixe mesmo como é isso
essa pergunta joga
[Música]
S
betis
[Música]
na cama
o brilho
que tal
uma diminuição de
consistente
[Música]
devido a deslocalização
chegar a este ponto acima aqui
prática de bicicleta
trazer contra produto diferente
meu conselho
estagnado
nós queremos dizer
e desafetos
[Música]
d
normal
[Música]
quando primo
o 4 certo
e por que
[Música]
e causar outra maneira
que todos os caminhos todas as máquinas
também pressionando contra o sapato
[Música]
primeiro emprestar
estes contínuos dentro
[Música]
no prisma
satisfazer com prazer
nunca termina aqui eu ainda estou
eu
[Música]
ponto
primeiro, mas esta equipe
e para pesquisar
[Música]
e essa parte de abertura
equipe de busca
esta parte
S
[Música]
estar neste peso de frente que carregamos
nós
estender três anos
30 mil vezes com sua música
pequena
Isso é longo
[Música]
isso
e
[Música]
e ponto
e logo e logo